Estamos en el problema 21, nos dicen,
esta es la solución de Juan a una ecuación, no la he revisado aún pero nos preguntan:
¿cuál enunciado relacionado con la
solución de Juan es verdadero?
revisemos la solución y veamos si lo
hizo bien o tuvo un error
veamos como la hizo mmm... creo que lo mejor es que la hagamos nosotros
la ecuación es "n" más 8 que multiplica a "n" más 20 es igual a 110
lo primero que vamos a hacer, es distribuir este 8 multiplicándolo por "n" más 20
no podemos empezar con esta suma, tenemos que seguir el orden de las operaciones
así es que hagamos esta multiplicación primero,
tenemos entonces "n" más 8 por "n" más 8 por 20 = 160
y esto que es igual a 110, 8 por "n" "8n"
8 por 20 = 160
y aquí al ver su desarrollo y el nuestro me
doy cuenta que hay un error
está "n" coincide, también coincide "8n",
pero él no hizo 8 por, 20 no hizo bien la distribución,
8 por 20 son 160, no 20 como él tiene aquí
así es que aquí es 160
así es que Juan cometió un error en el paso 1.
Ya no tenemos que revisar los demás pasos, todo va a estar mal después de ese error.
Problema 22.
¿Cuándo es verdadero el siguiente enunciado?
El opuesto de un número es menor
que el número original...
El opuesto de un número es menor que el número original.
Veamos si el número es negativo, el opuesto
del número va a ser positivo,
el cual no va a ser menor a ese número,
pero si el número es positivo, su opuesto es negativo,
el cual es menor al número.
De acuerdo, un número negativo es menor a un número positivo o equivalentemente...
un número positivo o equivalentemente,
si "x" es mayor que 0
entonces,
"-x" es menor que "x"
Si "x" es positivo, entonces definitivamente
-3 es menor que 3
Así es que, el enunciado es verdadero para
números positivos, la respuesta "c".
La respuesta "a", el enunciado nunca es verdadero, es falsa, ya vimos que si se puede cumplir
-3 y 3, es un ejemplo de esto.
La respuesta "b" el enunciado siempre es verdadero, también es falsa, -3 su opuesto es 3 que es mayor a -3
y de el enunciado es verdadero para números negativos,
no con el mismo ejemplo -3 su
opuesto es 3 que es mayor a el.
Problema 23.
¿Cuál es la ordenada al origen de la gráfica "d"?
déjame ver... 23, nos dan la ecuación "4x" más "2y" igual a 12,
si nosotros graficaramos esta ecuación, la ordenada al origen es el punto donde la recta intersecta el eje "y"
ese punto que tenemos ahí,
la coordenada en "y" de ese punto
y esa intersección se da, cuando la coordenada
en "x" es igual a 0 ¿de acuerdo?
así es que la coordenada de ese punto va a
ser 0, la ordenada al origen
así es que lo más fácil, es a partir de la ecuación, ver cuánto vale "y" cuando "x" vale 0
así es que cuando "x" es igual a 0
"4x" se hace 0
y nos queda "2y" es igual a 12, de donde "y" es igual a 6
la respuesta es la opción "c",
lo único que queremos saber es cuando "x" es igual a 0
¿donde se intersecta la recta con el eje "y"?
esa es la ordenada al origen.
Siguiente problema.
Bien aquí nos dan una gráfica
nos dicen...
déjame copiar y pegar esto
bien...
Copiar
y pegar,
ahí lo tenemos,
¿Cuál desigualdad se muestra en la gráfica de abajo?
para empezar,
encontremos la ecuación de esta recta de aquí,
aquí vemos que la ordenada al origen es cuándo "x" es igual a 0 "y" es igual a -1
recordemos que para poner la ecuación de una recta en su forma pendiente ordenada
esta es "y" igual a "mx" más "b"
donde "m" es la pendiente y "b" la ordenada al origen
aquí cuando "x" es igual a 0 "y" es igual a -1
así es que la ordenada al origen es igual a -1
así es que "b" es igual a -1
tenemos ahora que "y" es igual a "mx" -1 nos hace falta entonces encontrar la pendiente
y la pendiente es cómo cambia "y" conforme cambia "x" vamos a calcularlo entonces.
queremos calcular el cambio en "y"
dado el cambio en "x"
¿y qué tenemos?
vemos en la gráfica que cuando
"x" cambia 2 unidades, "y" cambia 1 unidad
es decir ,"y" cambia 1 unidad cada que
"x" cambia 2 unidades
también podríamos haber calculado que
cuando "x" cambia 4 unidades
"y" cambia en 2 unidades
esto también es igual a 2/4
que es igual a, 1/2.
En fin ya conocemos la pendiente
que es el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x",
por lo cual la ecuación de la recta es:
"y" igual a 1/2 de "x" menos 1
esa es la ecuación de esta recta,
pero lo que nos están preguntando
es la ecuación de la desigualdad.
Para empezar, en la región sombreada
están incluyendo la recta,
aquí está marcada la región gris y
la recta está marcada con una línea continua
si lo hubieran trazado con una línea punteada,
entonces la recta no estaría incluida en la desigualdad,
es decir, la desigualdad es mayor o igual
o menor o igual, pues se incluye la recta
en este problema las opciones son:
"y" mayor igual a un medio de "x" menos 1 ó
"y" menor igual a un medio de "x" menos 1,
veamos qué pasa para una "x" dada por ejemplo cuando "x" es igual a 2,
si "x" es igual a 2 y lo sustituimos en esta expresión,
obtenemos "y" igual a 0 es este punto sobre la recta.
Entonces para los puntos que se
encuentran en esta zona gris...
para ese valor de "x" los valores de "y"
¿son mayores que 0 ó son menores que 0?
claramente los valores de "y" son mayores que 0
son los valores de "y" que se encuentran por arriba...
de los valores de "y" que están determinados
por esta ecuación.
Así es que la desigualdad que representa la zona gris que tenemos en la gráfica
es esta desigualdad que tenemos aquí,
y es muy fácil tomar la decisión a ojo
dado que estamos incluyendo la recta, el signo va a ser mayor o igual o menor o igual
y como la zona sombreada se encuentra
por arriba de la recta...
entonces la desigualdad es mayor o igual
y esa es la opción "d".
Opción "d".
Siguiente problema.
Problema 25, éste es otro problema
en el cual necesitamos
copiar y pegar
está grande...
Bien aquí lo tenemos
¿Cuál representa mejor la gráfica de "y"
igual a "2x" menos 2?
entonces su pendiente es 2, 2 positivo,
y su ordenada el origen es -2, a simple vista podemos identificar la ordenada al origen,
en esta gráfica la ordenada al origen es -2,
en esta gráfica también es -2,
en las dos gráficas de abajo la ordenada
al origen es 2 positiva
aquí la tenemos ordenada al origen 2,
así que sabemos que la ordenada al origen es -2,
Ups ¿a dónde se fue?
¡Aquí está! sabemos que la solución es
una de estas dos gráficas
"a" o "c"
Tenemos que determinar cuál de estas dos tiene una pendiente positiva de 2,
en la gráfica "a" cuando avanzo 2 a la derecha,
avanzo 4 hacia arriba,
el cambio en "y" sobre el cambio en "x" es igual a:
avanzo 4 hacia arriba mientras avanzo 2 a la derecha...
avanzo 4 hacia arriba, cuando avanzo 2 a la
derecha, si es que la pendiente es 2
así es que esta recta tiene pendiente 2, la respuesta es "a" y aunque la opción "c" no es la correcta
analicemos cuánto vale la pendiente de esta recta.
Ubiquémonos en un punto arbitrario, por ejemplo,
este de "y" igual a -2
si avanzo 2 a la derecha ¿qué pasa con la "y"?
¿aumenta su valor o disminuye su valor?
en este caso la "y" está disminuyendo su valor,
está disminuyendo en 4
es decir, que aquí tenemos que el cambio en "y" sobre el cambio en "x", es igual
cuando avanzamos 2 positivo para la "x", en
"y" vamos a disminuir en 4
por lo que, la pendiente es -2
es fácil ver que una recta tiene pendiente negativa, cuando va bajando de izquierda a derecha
pero siempre puede ser estas flechas donde ves que al haber un avance hacia la derecha...
hay una disminución hacia abajo por lo cual
la pendiente es negativa
así es que para este problema la respuesta es "a".
Siguiente problema, nos están dando otro problema de identificar la desigualdad correspondiente...
a una región sombreada de una gráfica,
son interesantes,
Afortunadamente siempre podemos copiar y pegar....
Aquí lo tenemos, nos preguntan,
¿cuál desigualdad la región sombreada
de la gráfica representa?
de nueva cuenta, lo mejor es encontrar para empezar la ecuación de esta recta
a simple vista podemos determinar
que la ordenada al origen es 2
y ahora ¿cuál es la pendiente?
cuando "x" aumenta en 1...
cuando "x" aumenta en 1 "y" baja en 3...
"y" baja en 3, tenemos entonces que para esta recta la ordenada al origen es 2, fue lo primero que notamos,
y la pendiente es, el cambio en "y"
sobre el cambio en "x"
vimos que cuando "x" avanza en 1,
"y" baja en 3, el cambio en "y" va a ser -3
así es que la pendiente es igual a -3
y la ecuación de la recta es "y" igual a "-3x" más 2
"y" igual a "mx" más "b", y si vemos las
opciones que tenemos...
bien, están en una forma ligeramente diferente, a como está la ecuación que obtuvimos,
pero vamos a obtener la desigualdad.
Para empezar, la desigualdad va a ser
mayor o igual o menor o igual,
incluimos el igual pues la línea está
comprendida en la región
para cualquier valor de "x" por ejemplo,
cuando "x" es igual a 2...
cuando "x" es igual a 2, de acuerdo a esta ecuación, el valor de "y" es igual a -4
ahora, ¿estamos incluyendo en la región los valores de "y" que son mayores ese valor...
o los valores de "y" que son menores ese valor?
aquí vemos que estamos incluyendo los valores de "y" que son menores a ese valor
así es que esa región representa la desigualdad "y" menor o igual a "-3x" más 2
a simple vista al ver que estos valores
están por debajo de la recta,
podemos determinar que la desigualdad
es menor o igual,
incluimos el igual, pues la recta está
comprendida en la region,
si fuera una línea punteada sería estrictamente menor,
pero como dijimos esta no es la forma
en la que están las respuestas
aquí pusieron las "x" y las "y" del mismo
lado podemos hacer eso
sumando "3x" a ambos lados de la
desigualdad ¿qué nos da?
"3x" más "y"
esto es menor o igual que "-3x" más "3x" se cancelan y nos queda simplemente 2,
la región sombreada de la gráfica
representa la desigualdad
"3x" más "y" menor o igual que 2 que es la opción "a".
Se me ha acabado el tiempo
nos vemos en el siguiente video.